that's because that's never been his
game and it's gonna have to be I love
the shooting from deep but it's got to
use that big body
speaking of shooting conceit Brandon
Clark Memphis leading by three just
underway here in the first quarter
Evans off the Clark screen and there he
is again
Wow so a lot of meditation and learned
how to stay present and be mindful it's
really helped his game and there's a
look at Grace and Allen inside they got
to be your scout team quarterback they
got a play when necessary Oh making his
presence felt
got a body underneath OOP scoring this
young man comes out third team All Big
Ten as a sophomore second as a junior
first team as a senior Harris Lee you
know patience is always key in this
league you have 82 games you have
short-term memory you got to move on to
the next game you played with a great
point guard last year Jaron you're gonna
play with one and he's on your left what
have you told John about his rookie year
in the NBA coming up the up turns it
over another Timberwolves turnover there
eight Brandon Carter I was just about to
say he's been loved the Aussie man he
had a cup of coffee last year with the
Nets harvey missing Clark and he put T
up in the weight room watch him chase
the basketball keeps his eye on it and
finishes and you notice now listen Bates
Diop that's what we talked about mark
he had an easy opportunity to grab that
defensive rebound little Lubbock Texas
up to Minneapolis Buddy Holly's hometown
you know three-point lead for the
Grizzlies approaching seven and a half
to go Mark Jones alongside Fran
Fraschilla and George Sodano Murphy
missed it got it back through contact
and he can tie in with a free throw in
this size his whole college career used
to scoring over big guys and pursuing
the basketball couldn't get the rebound
two-point lead for the Grizzlies 610 to
go dusty anis T man coaching experience
in summer league he's done a great job
of orchestrating this team Allen with a
nice hesitation move and got to the
bucket boy he's been a different player
here in the second half rent isolate him
and he's doing his thing giving him some
confidence 9 nothing run by the
Grizzlies finally ended by Mitch Creek
got to the bucket extra pass Diaw
couldn't get it and that's gonna do it
the Memphis Grizzlies go undefeated in
summer league play
to win the championship what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content